good morning John it's Friday do you
remember my previous Mulla Mulla based
promised to bring you weird animals more
often
I have solidified this idea every month
for the next year I'm gonna have one
video on this channel that is about a
weird amazing animal and there's also
gonna be a little bit more to this idea
that I'll tell you about at the end of
the video and I wanted to start with
another old favorite of mine octopuses
in general are of course very good and
weird with their chemical sensing
suckers and distributed nervous systems
and gelatinous muscle bodies and one of
the things you hear about octopuses is
that the only hard part of their bodies
are their beaks and they can fit through
anything larger than the size of that
beak and that is true of some octopuses
but there are actually two sub orders of
octopod ah there's serie de and in serie
de and sea rat octopuses have internal
shells like squids do and they use those
shells as anchors for mussels because
they swim differently than the insert
octopuses were used to they have ears
they don't actually have ears they have
flappy fins above their eyes that look
like ears that they use for efficient
swimming and steering there's a group of
sea rat octopuses that are named for
these weird ears that they use to fly
through the sea they're called Dumbo
octopuses for obvious reasons and
they're really great and they are deeply
mysterious there are 13 possibly 14
possibly 11 known species of Dumbo
octopus we're pretty confused because
several of them have only been found one
time including one that hasn't been seen
since the 1800s oh my god what are you
doing that's really cute does that mean
they're rare have humans and our
dastardly humanization of the world
destroy these peculiar beauties no
actually they're probably fine it's hard
to know that it's live in parts of the
ocean that are very difficult to get to
there are indeed probably way more
species of Dumbo octopus than we know
about because they're very good at
living deep down usually between 10,000
and 13,000 feet though one species has
been found 23,000 feet down for
comparison the deepest spot in the ocean
is 36 thousand feet below sea level so
these little cuties live down deep most
of the footage in this video was taken
by the ocean exploration trusts
exploration vessel Nautilus so thanks to
them for that one
biggest problems animals and the deep
sea have to solve isn't how to survive
they do that mostly by moving very
efficiently and eating things that move
very slowly and not having very much
competition but to breed you need to
like encounter any member of the
opposite sex and while that happens it's
likely that it won't happen when the
female has lots of extra energy and a
great place to lay and protect eggs so
when a male Dumbo octopus meets a female
he just hands over a little package of
sperm and is like hey use this whenever
it works for you bye and then the female
can wait until she's in a really good
situation to care for her eggs before
fertilizing them so Dumbo octopuses are
good because they're cute and strange
and mysterious and huge at family
planning look at those ears I know
they're not ears but look at them anyway
John I can't wait to hit you next month
with another bizarre beast and here is
the extra part of the project to help
raise money for our communities work
decreasing maternal mortality in Sierra
Leone we are doing the dftba pin pals
bizarre beasts pin subscription club
that's right do you see it do you see
this Dumbo octopus on my lapel it was
there the whole time no it wasn't I
wasn't wearing this before his pin will
have three different flavors a common an
uncommon and a rare and it's $12 a month
free shipping everywhere in the world
and you can only get it for this week
for the whole year that's the young
times gonna be available and also John
tomorrow is Esther day so everybody get
ready to tell the people that you love
that you love them John I'll see you on
Tuesday
thanks again to the ocean exploration
trust their Nautilus live project is
amazing and it's constantly live
streaming on YouTube I've put some links
to their work here on the screen and in
the description